hey Crazy's back in 1959 two physicists
published paper and the physical review
they suggested that maybe we've been
imagining the electromagnetic field all
wrong
they even outlined an experiment to
prove it an experiment that almost broke
locality this episode was made possible
by generous supporters on patreon okay
first order of business what the heck is
locality it's easily one of the most
important principles in all of physics
it states that the behavior of an object
or particle should only be influenced by
events or phenomena at the location of
said object or particle the universe is
inherently local in other words for two
things to affect each other
they have to be at the same place it's
kind of a big deal and not like big deal
clone like an actual big deal hey anyway
most forces require physical contact to
work things have to touch each other but
even before quantum mechanics came along
we knew this locality principle had a
few notable exceptions gravity being the
most obvious it seems to be able to
reach out over unimaginable distances it
makes this squirrel fall near the
surface of the earth but it also keeps
the moon in orbit around the earth and
the planets around the Sun and the stars
inside the galaxy which you know seems a
little strange but rather than give up a
locality we consider the possibility
that maybe that effect isn't direct
instead of the earth affecting this rock
maybe the earth does something to space
and it's the space that affects the rock
it's something we call a field a number
or set of numbers assigned to points in
space in classical or Newtonian physics
that field is made up of arrows called
vectors in general relativity it's made
up of curvature tensors but it's still a
field it's a number or set of numbers
assigned to points in space
isn't that a little mathematical yes but
so is everything else in physics
lots of mathematical things represent
something real for example we represent
motion with a velocity arrow
the motion is real the velocity arrow is
not it's the map that represents the
real thing the same is true for the
gravitational field I mean it's not like
my hand is hitting a bunch of arrows
right now but locality says the earth
can't affect this rock directly so the
force must be due to something where the
rock is we call that a gravitational
field and represent it with a bunch of
arrows it's not a substance or a fluid
or anything but it's something something
is there and whatever it is it preserves
the principle of locality the earth
creates a field and it's that field that
affects the rock we can very easily
extend this concept to electricity and
magnetism charges don't affect each
other over a distance one charge creates
an electric field and that field affects
the second charge magnets don't affect
each other over a distance either one
magnet creates a magnetic field and that
field affects the second magnet locality
is preserved or is it in this video we
learned that the behavior of a particle
is described by a wave something we call
a quantum wave function I also mentioned
that that wave is unobservable and
that's true it is but if we have two
particles we might be able to see a
difference this wave could have started
here or here or even here as time plays
out you can see these waves are out of
sync we say they're out of phase in time
but all three of those waves describe
the same particle it's something we call
global phase and variance you want the
wave to start here instead of here
quantum particle don't care the
probabilities you calculate from that
wave function will be the same
regardless but back in 1959 two
physicists proposed an experiment that
calls everything into question say we've
got a device that emits electrons that
are all in phase that means their waves
are all synched if we separate two of
those electrons and then bring them back
together they should still be in phase
and that's exactly what happens when we
do the experiment we get a pattern on a
detection screen that is consistent with
two
in Phase wait what's that screen made of
what kind of electron device how are you
separating the electrons none of that
matters don't get hung up on unimportant
details all that matters here is that
they're in phase at the end how we got
there is completely irrelevant okay so
we get a pattern on a detector screen
that is consistent with two waves in
phase everything is fine so far no
problems at all now let's consider a
second device called a solenoid that's
just a long densely packed coil of wire
nothing too fancy if we run an electric
current through that wire we'll get a
magnetic field but only inside the coil
outside the coil the field is so weak
you might as well just say it's zero
things start to get weird when we use
this coil in our experiment say we place
the coil in the middle so the two
electrons go around the outside there's
no field out there so the principle of
locality says they shouldn't be affected
things should only be affected by other
things at their location except those
electrons are affected we get a
different pattern on the detector screen
the electron waves are out of phase what
would what I know right somehow the
magnetic field here is affecting
electrons all the way out here that
shouldn't be possible
so do we finally give up in locality
then not so fast this phase effect is
called the aharonov-bohm effect after
the two physicists who proposed the
experiment thankfully those same two
physicists the physicists physics
physics physicists thankfully those same
two physicists also proposed a solution
what if there is something in the space
the electrons are passing through we
know there's no magnetic field but maybe
the magnetic field isn't the best way to
look at this in basic mechanics you
normally use forces and Newton's second
law
that's where electric and magnetic
fields are the most useful an electric
field is a force per unit charge it
tells you how much force could be
exerted on a charge at that point the
magnetic field does the same thing for
magnets and moving charges the two of
them together allow us to find an
electromagnetic force
but forces are not the only way to look
at a situation sometimes energy and
momentum can give you a deeper insight
take this battery for example it is a
voltage of 1.5 volts and the voltage
just the Joule per Coulomb in energy per
unit charge what that means is the
energy at the positive end of the
battery is 1.5 volts higher than the
energy at the negative end of the
battery that number isn't just limited
to those two locations though this
battery assigns a number like that to
every point in space it's something we
call the electric potential and since
that number is assigned to every point
in space it's a field a scalar field
this number tells us the energy that one
Coulomb of charge would receive from the
battery at each location in space
however the solenoid in our experiment
doesn't have an electric potential
around it it has a magnetic potential
which fulfills a similar purpose but for
momentum instead of energy since
momentum is a vector so is the magnetic
potential which is why we call it a
vector potential we have one of these
magnetic potential fields around our
solenoid and it solves our locality
problem the electrons in our experiment
pass right through the magnetic
potential and it predicts the phase
difference we see on the detection
screen so locality it's kind of a big
deal
things should only affect other things
at their locations
it's a principle that we see obeyed over
and over and over again if you want to
affect something over a distance you
have to send something between you and
that thing maybe that exchange happens
because of a physical object
oh how maybe it happens because there's
some kind of field but no matter what
even in weird quantum experiments like
this one there is something local
locality must be preserved at all costs
so if you have any questions please ask
in the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us if you like what we do and have it to
spare please consider pledging on
patreon even a dollar a month helps keep
things stable around here and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
wait what about
aash the featured comment comes from
feinstein 100 who pointed out how
amazing the quantum wave function is I
admit it is amazing but that doesn't
make it real it's more like a coded
message in order to make sense of it you
have to decode it first it's the decoded
information that's real anyway thanks
for watching